so saturday night live has basically
just become woke journalists talking to
each other they don't even do anything
that's funny anymore every skit is
essentially left-wing talking points
filtered through a mildly
comedic lens
maybe maybe so the worst skit on snl
over the weekend was a skit
that i don't even know what this is
supposed to be so colin jost is the is
the guy jose jost the guy weekend update
is the weekend update and then
he brings forth another person whose
name i don't know does any producers do
you know the name of this person who's
playing
an actual clown
i i don't know who this person is nor do
i frankly care so i'm not going to hold
up the show on that basis anyway colin
jost jost
he has on
a person dresses a clown to talk about
abortion
it's about as funny as it sounds
it's basically like hannah gadsby and
samantha b
had a comedy baby and by a comedy baby i
mean had a
a
lump of something that is not a baby and
is not comedy
it's just poop
that's what it's like um i don't know
who wrote this i don't know who thought
it was funny
the audience is just sort of laughing
awkwardly because they don't even know
what's going on it doesn't make any
internal sense
but the left is so proud and obsessed
with abortion at this point they're so
proud of and obsessed with abortion at
this point that they literally think
they can just dress a person up as a
clown and do planned parenthood talking
points and people will laugh and cheer
and apparently if you're in new york
filming this thing uh they will so here
is some of the worst skit i have ever
seen on snl
here to cheer us up well this can't be
right goober the clown who had an
abortion when she was 23.
so
goober you had an abortion when you were
23. whoa slow down i'm a clown let's
clown around hey smell this flower
you're not gonna squirt me are you oh i
would never
okay oh gotcha gotcha i had an abortion
the day before my 23rd birthday
okay
so you think that this is just going to
be like an inappropriate clown right so
stop for a second you think that you
think this skit's going to be an
inappropriate clown just saying
inappropriate things right wrong that's
not what the skit is
like that'd actually be funny
if there's like a children's clown who
just blurted out inappropriate things
about her own life that might be a funny
idea for a skit nope that's not what the
skit is the skit is an actual lecture
about abortion from a clown well
actually i really don't but people keep
bringing it up so i gotta keep talking
about freaking abortion but it's a rough
subject so we're gonna do fun clown
stuff to make it more palatable
it goes on like this for a solid four
minutes
and
this person dressed as a clown informs
us that she had an abortion at 23
and that everyone in the united states
apparently has had an abortion like so
many women have had an abortion and that
makes it okay
the best quote from this is there is one
point during this little skit in which
this person says quote i know i wouldn't
be a clown on tv here today if it
weren't for the abortion i had the day
before my 23rd birthday
i don't think you're getting across the
point you mean to get across when you
say it like that
i know i wouldn't be a clown on tv here
today if it weren't for the abortion i
had the day before my 23rd birthday
yes indeed nothing makes the moral case
for killing an unborn baby like saying
you needed an abortion so you could
become a person who dressed up as a
clown on national tv to talk about your
abortion
i mean when i think of like things i
want on my epitaph like right on my
gravestone it would be dressed up as a
clown to talk about abortion on national
tv just right there on the epitaph if
that means i got to kill a baby to do it
well you know
life has cost there are ups and there
are downs
but the fact that that is the way that
they approach the skit like this entire
it's not a skit it's literally just a
person dressed up as a clown who then
explains to you that many women just
calls women clowns basically that many
women have had abortions and therefore
abortion is not only okay it is good and
that women should comfort each other for
having had abortions and should at no
point ask a moral question about whether
that abortion was a good idea or a bad
idea and no point does the humanity of
the unborn baby come into it of course
the the late the last argument that is
made there that one i will never get
over that argument made by
so-called pro-choice activists i say
so-called because in the vast fast fast
vast majority of cases of unplanned
pregnancy there was a choice made that
led to the pregnancy
okay sex can lead to pregnancy so
accepting cases of rape and incest which
are a huge minority of abortions you're
talking about people engaging in willing
sex and then
there's an unplanned pregnancy
okay to pretend that there's no element
of choice there is very silly anyway
the the so-called pro-choice case that
rests upon my life is so much better
because i kill the baby is such a wild
end around the morality when it comes to
abortion
it is such a
a dodging of the fundamental question
i'm sure there are lots of things in
life that if you did and were immoral
would make your life better it's like
saying well you know
as a as a habit i just tend to walk into
banks shoot the teller and take the cash
and let me just tell you this house that
i have here this beautiful nice house i
definitely would not have that if i had
not walked directly into the bank shot
the teller in the face and took the
money i mean so i guess it was i guess
it was worth it i guess it was good
but it just demonstrates the lightness
the moral lightness with which the left
takes the killing of the unborn
that they don't even attempt in their
own logical minds to justify some sort
of great accomplishment justified by
abortion it's not even like i had to
become a senator so i boarded a baby
which would be bad enough right that'd
be terrible but they're like
i couldn't have dressed up as a clown on
snl
if i didn't have this abortion when i
was 23. it's like oh you mean you might
actually have had to be a mother
and take care of your child
who was your kid
like as a meaningful human
yeah
there's a reason that the pro-choice
movement is not gaining adherence these
days and a large part of that is they're
moved from safe legal and rare to shout
your abortion abortion as positive good
celebrate your abortion on national tv
while dressed up as a clown
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment